[Musica]
[Applauso]
secondo voi può un libertino impenitente
donnaiolo essere trasformato in un
emblema in un esempio dell'amore
romantico dolce puro sublime poi il
pregiudizio su un personaggio
essenzialmente negativo essere
modificato grazie allievi alterazioni
all'interno di una melodia
andiamo a vedere se e come questo può
accadere nella parafrasi sul rigoletto
composta da franz liszt uno dei più
grandi compositori dell'ottocento e
pianista assolutamente leggendario
attorno al quale è sorto ogni genere di
aneddoto sia per le sue capacità
pianistiche strabilianti sia perché ha
avuto una vita mondana molto molto
chiacchierata e numerosissime relazioni
anche poco accettate da dall epoca in
cui viveva che anche oggi risultano
abbastanza sconveniente infatti era
adorata dalle donne sia per la sua
figura molto bella sia perché avevamo
una cultura immensa sia come ho detto
delle capacità pianistica inaudita
ebbene list che ha avuto una vita
davvero varia da mattatore assoluto di
delle sale di tutta europa era il più
richiesto è il più pagato il più adorato
pianista certo punto all'apice del
successo si è ritirato a
vita quasi privata per comporre per
dedicarsi alla composizione e
addirittura nell'ultima parte della sua
vita e ha preso gli ordini minori
diventando abate bene a questo
personaggio così eccezionale ma allo
stesso tempo così umano con delle
inquietudini che riconosciamo ancora
come nostre ha scritto moltissime
parafrasi riduzione trascrizioni che
erano una sorta di youtube dell'epoca
infatti in un periodo in cui non
esisteva ancora la riproduzione digitale
riproduzione del suono è l'unico modo
per fruire in città di provincia in
posti in cui per ordinare luigi per
motivi di ordine logistico non era
possibile avere grandi orchestre dei
teatri capienti e nelle scene eccetera
l'unica possibilità in questi posti per
fruire del repertorio sinfonico e
operistico era appunto le riduzioni le
trascrizioni le parafrasi in pratica la
parafrasi è una trascrizione quasi
letterale di una scena di un'opera è ma
in quel quasi come andremo a vedere ci
può essere una differenza enorme che può
creare dei corto circuiti che che
generano delle differenze considerevole
soprattutto quando la parafrasi composta
da un genio come franz liszt
l'opera ha presa da liste il rigoletto
la scena il quartetto
rigoletto è un opera di giuseppe verdi
rigoletto un gobbo che lavora come
buffone di corte presso il duca di
mantova che è proprio l'esempio la
personificazione del del nobile senza
scrupoli assolutamente sprezzante dei
diritti dai propri sudditi un donnaiolo
eccetera
ebbene il duca di mantova seduce con un
inganno fingendosi uno studente
squattrinato proprio la figlia di
rigoletto che il suo bene più caro e la
disonora per dirla con un termine un po
demodé ma che appropriato a quello che
dice proprio gilda nell'opera dice
l'onta ecco nonostante l'onda gilda
continua ad essere innamorata del duca e
rigoletto nella scena del quartetto
vuole mostrare proprio a lei quanto in
costante e menzognero e assolutamente
non degno di fiducia sia questo
personaggio è infatti io lo mostra
mentre corteggia un'altra donna
maddalena è la corteggia con le stesse
promesse probabilmente con delle corone
sia abbastanza simili a quelle che aveva
fatto la gilda e dopo questa scena
rigoletto per vendicarsi del duca e
assolda un sicario che però è il
fratello di maddalena e per
intercessione di questa il sicario che
dovrebbe uccidere il duca uccide alla
fine proprio gilda anche per il
sacrificio di quest'ultima cosicché
rigoletto si ritrova suo malgrado a
sacrificare proprio quello che era il
suo bene più prezioso
ritornando al quartetto verdi
caratterizza con dei profili melodici e
psicologici assolutamente peculiari ogni
personaggio così che la natura delle
emozioni del momento è davvero
chiarissima il
[Musica]
come vi ho detto sta corteggiando
maddalena e le sue parole sono quelle
che abbiamo appena sentito che questo
video un tratto da amici miei
bella figlia dell'amore schiavo sono
divisi tuoi con un detto solto puoi le
mie pene con solar vieni e senti del mio
cuore i frequente per partita
insomma sono delle parole molto toccanti
il punto è che suonano abbastanza
beffarde nell'opera perché il duca
appena cantato questo quella per me pari
sono e poi la donna è mobile qual piuma
al vento multa da 100 e di pensiero il
caso dell area decisamente maschilista
in cui la donna è considerata poco più
che un oggetto e quindi le parole che
suonano un po false
[Musica]
del profilo melodico è molto nobile e
maddalena risponde a questa corte e
quasi sta ammazzando perché è
naturalmente le fa molto piacere è
quindi ci sembra ecco e molte molte ci
vettura dalla sua risposta le dice arido
ben di core che taiba e tali parole
costan poco quanto valga il vostro gioco
mail credete su apprezzati verdi la
caratterizza con delle note staccate e
che rendono bene appunto l'idea del
personaggio che finge in qualche maniera
di schermi da questa corte ma
fondamentalmente fa piacere gilda invece
è che è il personaggio che soffre tutta
questa situazione ha naturalmente di un
profilo melodico decisamente diverso
quindi lei dice infelice core core
tradito per angoscia non scoppiare e
queste parole hanno un evoluzione nel
corso del por tetto fino ad arrivare
verso la fine a suonare così
quasi come se gilda non riuscisse a
parlare come se avessero bisogno di di
singhiozzare tra le parole tanto il
dolore di vedere ri assisterà una
situazione del genere
e poi c'è rivoletto insomma ha un
profilo più di me che sta dicendo a di
gilda di non curarsi di un personaggio
del genere perché non ha e non è
assolutamente meritevole della sua
attenzione
e intanto comincia a progettare la sua
vendetta
ora cosa succede nella parafrasi di
liszt e la scena non si apre con il duca
ma si apre in qualche maniera
con lui perché lì si mostra subito le
sue conseguenze ovvero ci mostra i due
personaggi femminili messi uno dopo
l'altro quindi le conseguenze delle
azioni del duca inserita nella stessa
nella stessa frase così che possiamo
confrontare immediatamente quindi c'è
maddalena
[Musica]
ancora maddalena un po più cupa
questa introduzione continua con
un'altra breve pagina quasi arpa e
finalmente entra in scena il duca e la
differenza rispetto all'originale
verdiana è abbastanza è abbastanza
evidente perché liste lo immerge in un
languore è in una malinconia che non era
presente in verdi sicuramente non così
evidente e lo fa togliendo tutti i
riferimenti ritmici questi quindi
immergendo questa melodia quasi senza
tempo e poi crea delle dissonanze delle
appoggiature dei ritardi che danno al
personaggio una sorta di malinconia e di
dolcezza sicuramente maggiore rispetto a
quelle che avevano l'originale verdiana
e quindi è quasi come se il list stesse
guardando forse con un pizzico di ironia
ma anche con indulgenza quello che è il
comportamento del duca ma anche quello
che è stato era stata forse anche il suo
comportamento nella sua prima fase
scrivere questo va infatti nella seconda
fase quella in cui totalmente dedito
alla composizione e quindi ci appare un
personaggio che ama pienamente il cui
amore veramente sincero ma forse a tempo
determinato e quindi appare così
[Musica]
cosa succede quindi che questa melodia
in qualche maniera attrae tutto il resto
da qui in poi quindi gli altri per la
melodia verrà ripetuta altre altre due
volte e gli altri personaggi li vediamo
quasi sfocati così sullo sfondo di
quello che è l'amore del duca e finché
dopo l'ultima cadenza dopo dopo l'ultima
ripetizione di questa melodia e il
nostro occhio di bue immaginario
finalmente ci mostra gilda 15 mostrare
il personaggio che soffre da questa
situazione e list ci indica in quel
momento ci indica dolce e con somma
passion a liszt conosceva l'italiano
quindi avrebbe potuto indicarci per
esempio con dolore o con l'angoscia
eccetera
forse non è casuale questa scelta perché
è come se il personaggio venisse il
dolore di questo personaggio venisse
trasfigurato dall'amore del lupo come se
l'amore del duca venisse trasfigurato
dal dolore questo personaggio non si sa
ma suona circa così
[Musica]
dopo una ripetizione di questo tema in
chiave più virtuosistica cioè la
parafrasi si sta quasi per concludersi
ma laddove la scena di verdi era
conclusa c'è una giunta da parte di
liszt riappare il duca ma riappare con
un dubbio
[Musica]
ma se si chiedesse ma sarà comunque
giusto tutto ciò
[Musica]
maddalena
e ora gilda
[Musica]
e poi dopo un attimo di pausa è come se
il duca dicesse ma sì chi vuol esser
lieto sia del doman non v'è certezza
e si conclude la fase con un passaggio
molto virtuosistico è davvero esultante
che suona quasi fuori luogo rispetto a
quel dubbio sincero che abbiamo appena
sentito forse il dubbio che sono fuori
luogo rispetto a questo finale così
trionfare e mi viene ammette che prima
di questa scena mentre il duca ha già
cominciato a fare la corte a maddalena
lei lo esorta ad essere saggio e il duca
risponde ogni saggezza chiudersi nel
gaudio è nell'amore
ora chiudersi significa ogni saggezza si
porta al suo compimento massimo nel
gaudio nell'amore oppure ogni saggezza
al cospetto di gaudio e amore
sparisce non lo so è un'interpretazione
che rimane aperta
non so quanto sia giusto dare un
giudizio morale su questo comportamento
su questo atteggiamento però possiamo
possiamo vedere cosa cosa ci dice la
musica ma ascolta
[Musica]
[Applauso]